okay we're gonna get going now we have a
small class this year because of changes
in the Institute with pass/fail types of
things but Professor Martin and dr. syn
the dr. Rey and I consider this to be a
special opportunity for us to run the
course a little bit differently with a
few more quirks and surprises because we
have a small number of you we can listen
to you all we can get input from you we
can even get feedback from you of
something you might like to see more of
and in general we really want to capture
the sense of you I looked at the
registration list we have people from
every year we have people from many many
different disciplines so this is what
we're gonna do today after we I start
doing some introductions and so on we're
going to talk about the nitty-gritty of
the organization we need to tell you
this we need to convey this information
to you clearly about when exams are and
what requirements are and how to do well
in this course without even realizing it
that kind of thing and then I'll take
you through this sort of fast track
through molecules to man all the way
down to cells and organisms to show you
that there was a breakpoint in the 1950s
weather where the structure the
non-covalent structure of DNA was
elucidated and there was an entire
revolution after that which makes modern
biology the study of modern biology so
entirely different from the study of
biology in the era before that biology
used to be considered taxonomy and
dissection like listing and and looking
at but now biology modern biology is a
molecular science so as we talk about
these topics what you will see is the
blueprints for life a common across
domains of life and if you learn basic
principles you'll have an exponential
increase in your ability to appreciate
these characteristics the modern biology
is a synthesis
science technology engineering where all
the tools from those disciplines
different disciplines physics math
computation funnel into modern biology
to make what we know now feasible and
now that's a dramatic and fantastic
opportunity for all of you moving
forward in your careers now I want to
introduce the team so I'm Barbara
Imperiali
I'm a faculty member in chemistry and
biology and I'm really interested in
chemical biology glycobiology biophysics
I love to tease apart complex pathways
in organisms where we use synthesis by
Oh synthesize very unusual glycol
conjugates that are very important for
cell cell communication and host cell
pathogen communication for example I was
trained as an organic chemist in fact I
did my PhD degree at MIT about five
million years ago on a sort of current
scale so my co-instructor this is sorry
about this they want us on V Martin and
my lab is interested in how cells
generate mechanical forces and how this
is involved in sculpting tissues during
development so what Adam hasn't told you
is he's a cell biologist a biophysicist
and he's a lot better at genetics and I
am our instructor is dr. us divya ray
who's been with this course now this is
the sixth year and she is trained in
immunology cancer biology and also sells
cellular signaling but what you can't
tell from that is how dedicated she is
to each and every one of you if you have
any trouble in the semester just contact
dr. ray and say I need some help be it
you know a particular problem in the
material or there's just something come
up that makes it difficult for you to do
your best in the course she will help
you she'll work out
mechanisms to get you through troubled
spots so let's get going here now what I
want to try to do is just give you sort
of a flavor of where we're going to
within the course by starting with a few
sort of bullet points and topics just
that I can sort of pique your interest
so as I mentioned before studying
biology in the 21st century is a
fabulous opportunity no matter what
discipline you come from you can add to
the expertise that will move biology
forward biology would not be where it is
today in the absence of science
engineering to promote it and to support
progress in biology so you really want
to realize that that you have an
opportunity you may say well I'm in this
discipline or rather I don't think
biology is gonna have anything to do
with my future career on career
opportunities but it has a lot to do
with your life it has a lot to do with
understanding health and disease
understanding new scientific discoveries
and developments so it's so important
that you as a sort of a scholar of the
21st century have a good grasp on these
materials and we're not trying to feed
you anything dull and boring this is
really exciting stuff because the level
of complexity that we can study nowadays
whole genomes whole organisms at a
molecular level is amazing it's amazing
we're not just peering down a slide and
looking at you know one cell or
something we would be able to do full
descriptions so the what will try to
give you is a view of the fundamental
principles that are common to all living
organisms so the study of biology some
people a micro biologists or eukaryotic
biologists or human biologists or biruté
your or they study virology but we're
gonna build for you in the first few
weeks of class information on the common
building blocks that are go across all
domains of life because once you start
to learn about those molecules to build
up the macromolecules of life
then you'll start to really gain an
understanding how amazing it is that
these same sets of molecules function
across from bacteria to man so you learn
the rules for the simplest organisms you
look at the molecules and you see how
form fulfills function which is
something I'm really excited about and
then you'll be able to apply it as we
get evermore complex systems which which
demand a lot of attention so these are
common molecular there's a common
molecular logic a very complex processes
motivations I just mentioned a few sure
you want to understand health and
disease you want to understand what
might be going on with current therapies
when you have a relative who's been
diagnosed with a serious disease what
are the current opportunities what's
coming down what sorts of opportunities
for therapy might be available because
there are so many diseases now we
understand at a molecular level we may
not understand how to treat them yet but
we understand what their origin is and
that's why molecular approaches are so
important you may often hear words like
systems biology and synthetic biology
these are kind of jazzy words for fairly
straightforward things systems biology
is a little bit like treating an
organism or a cell as a lek Trickle
network a wiring diagram what what
proteins talk to what proteins what are
downstream functions where a signals
amplified and so on so that's systems
biology at its heart
quantifying different intermediates in a
complex map of the cell synthetic
biology is about using biology to make
stuff which is really cool many many
important molecules can be made in the
lab but it's so much more effective to
make them in an organism people are
doing what they call synthetic biology
and that's exploiting and harnessing
nature to make things that are useful
for mankind and all the way through what
I just want to emphasize how integrating
technology and engine
for science is really what we're all
about here because we appreciate we
couldn't make the progress without it
there are also issues a biology neural
biology impacts that are in the social
sciences and impinge on things like
ethics designer babies cloning people
cloning your pets all kinds of things
treating a disease through genetics or
not CRISPR casts some of these new
innovations but you really need to
understand ethical issues related to
them to be able to explain to your
parents or your grandparents or your
sister or brother who hasn't taken
biology what the implications of some of
the things that we can do in biology but
probably we shouldn't do in biology and
and we will welcome your thoughts on
some of that later on okay so where did
the world start arguably four and a half
billion years ago is kind of a big theme
but it started with the world the earth
being a ball of fire and it took quite a
while for it to cool down to establish
the hydrosphere and the globe as it's
known today there was a period of time
known as the prebiotic world where there
were not living organisms that
replicated and that was basically a
world where building blocks started to
evolve out of mud fiery hot mud pits and
in volcanoes and goodness knows what
where people believed that the building
blocks of life just the molecules came
together from things like hydrogen
cyanide or sulfide or other primordial
components that were in the primordial
soup there was a phase known as the pre
the pre RNA world where the RNA building
blocks were around there's reasonable
arguments in favor of the RNA world
where a lot of functions were catalyzed
not by proteins but by nucleic acids
specifically ribonucleic acids so
there's a period of time still prebiotic
that had the our excuse me that had the
first pre RNA and then our in a world
but then things really started
to get interesting when the first cells
evolved now I will talk a little bit
about this in the next class because the
thing that's critical to be able to
build a cell is to be able to build a
wall around it so very very early on in
life lipid bilayers membranes evolved in
order to make compartmentalized
structures where you could differentiate
the in from the out and so much of life
is completely reliant on the fact that
we're made of cells we're not just one
big sort of bucket of water with things
floating around in it because so much of
function becomes coordinated by cellular
compartmentalization through things
known as lipid bilayers which are semi
permeable membranes oxygen can move
across some small hydrophobic things can
move across but a lot of things get
either stuck in or stuck out so we'll
talk a lot about that
so the first prokaryotes were
cyanobacteria they're photosynthetic
bacteria it was quite a long time until
those unicellular organisms that totally
lacked a nucleus lacked a lot of
intracellular compartmentalization
evolved to eukaryotes and those cells
are different they're a hundred or
thousand times bigger they're complex
they're compartmentalised they can do a
lot of functions in a full organism
they're very differentiated and they
they may look different in muscle or in
heart or in skin or in bone and so those
eukaryotes so that's a long gap of time
but there was a lot going on in that
face and about a half a billion years
ago multicellular life involved and
multicellular life now can be looked at
if we think of the evolution of Homo
sapiens can be thought of as something
that we can keep track of a bit through
fossil records over the last five
million years where the first humanoid
life evolved then you got sort of to a
stage I think he's Homo ergaster this
sort of Shrek like person evolved quite
early on and then
the humanoid gradually became different
evolved in some cases there were
branches of the tree of evolution and
dead ends in other places there was a
branch that carried on for a while for
example the Neanderthal and Homo sapiens
kind of kept on evolving for a while but
there's a lot of developments that have
been characterized from the fossil
record but now there's a lot of belief
that if we trace things back through
genomes we might get more precise
information on steps in evolution how
the evolution of the advanced if you
will
hominids really came along with a number
of things there was a stage at which a
particular gene that the fox pee gene is
attributed to the ability to for complex
speech and that could have been a leap
forward when humanoids could communicate
more and it seems to be associated with
that but there are the sort of
sociological functions like burying the
dead or making jewelry or making tools
that are associated with the more
evolved organisms there are other types
of things like cranial capacity standing
upright looking forward a lot of things
came through those years of the
evolution of Homo sapiens so it's
fascinating to think about that and I
think what light genetics can shed on
those five million years of evolution
and now the the world of biology took a
mega kick start with the elucidation of
the human genome but more importantly of
the technology necessary to solve the
map of the human genome and in 2001
there was major development with the
publication of the first map of the
human genome it's fascinating to think
with humans
we humans have about 3 billion genes but
there's only across human is that right
no sorry base pairs yes thank you very
much but across like humankind there's
enormous diversity but that's accounted
for by only about 0.1
scent of that divert of the diversity so
you know you can see people look very
very different but we still share 99.9
percent of our genome and now the very
interesting thing is that genomes vary
in size quite considerably before I move
forward I just want to quickly show you
this map I mentioned looking at racing
evolution through a molecular clock so
looking back in time not by following
the shape of a skull for example or
physiologic changes but looking at
genomes using the genome as a molecular
clock based on mutation rates that are
fairly constant amongst domains of life
you couldn't compare a human and a
bacterium but you can go back through a
lot of eukaryotic evolution and see
where divergences happen so in this sort
of map you can see that human and the
and earth all diverged from the
chimpanzee a certain time ago which had
diverged from the gorilla further ago
based on the molecular clock that's
available okay so now I want to talk a
little bit more about getting into the
details of the genome so genomes differ
greatly in size our genome includes
about 3 billion base pairs in our 22
chromosomes plus the X and Y chromosome
but the typical genome of a model
bacterium is only 5 billion million base
pairs so far far smaller more tangible
more easy to study because those genes
are more limited in size but the genome
size is not necessarily proportionate to
the number of genes that are expressed
and made into proteins and a fascinating
discovery is that of the 3 billion base
pairs only about one and a half to two
percent actually code for proteins and
there's a ton of interest now and what's
the rest of the genome doing there where
did it come from what's its function
there are different functions that Eric
Lander calls the dark matter of the
genome different functions to the rest
of the genome
the part that we focus on is the part
that gets encoded into proteins that
form the functions of the molecules of
life so we're going to focus ourselves
in on those but here you see differences
in sizes of genomes based on base pair
but what's fascinating is despite this
huge breadth of sizes and huge
differences in organisms the building
blocks are the same and that's what I
think is the wonderful part of what
we're able to teach you is we can take
you from the 1950s when the structure of
double-stranded DNA was first solved now
there were 60 70 or more years of work
before that where they figured out the
pieces they figured out the chemistry
the covalent bonds in the basis and the
sugars and the phosphodiester but they
had no clue how the DNA could encode and
program the synthesis of a protein but
once the the see of the structure the
three-dimensional structure of
double-stranded DNA was solved this is
this beautiful antiparallel structure
that you see here by Watson Crick and
rosalind Franklin then the clues came
pouring in without that structure
without the structure of what's known as
the non-covalent structure not the
covalent structure you'll see all those
building blocks but the non covalent
structure how you could zipper apart the
two strands of DNA and make copies of
both of them and replicate DNA and then
go forward that was an amazing step
forward and for that there was a nobel
prize awarded unfortunately it was after
Franklin's death so it was given to
Watson and Crick and a third person you
know here's that structure of DNA a
beauty I could should watch it for hours
to be honest the phosphodiester
background backbone going up the back
and the bases base pairing across and
these are the key steps that happened
from the 50s so in the definite the
definition of the double-stranded
structure it took a few years but they
cracked that what's known as the genetic
code how does that DNA
get converted into a protein what
happens is you make a RNA copy of the
DNA and that RNA is read to make a
protein and you will learn about all
those components but that was another
real landmark then what was really
exciting is that some technology
companies started figuring out first
there were very slow ways to sequence
DNA but in that and that happened in
1977 but what was really important is
about a decade later where the ability
to sequence DNA was not done anymore
using huge agarose gels in a bucket of
radioactivity but it was done through
using fluorescence in order to allow you
to read out the sequence of DNA and you
will learn about that and in 1987 the
instruments were commercialized major
major technology and engineering we
wouldn't be anywhere without that in
1990 the human genome project began you
know one the draft of the human genome
sequence was completed 2010 you could
sequence a single strand of DNA one
molecule of DNA and now there's so many
initiatives that have come out of that
and so much amazing technology that has
evolved so things like the thousand
genome project to look at variation
across man so all people from all
different parts of world you can look up
that website that's very cool
the human cell Act lists there was quite
a bit of news about that in MIT
technology news where Aviv Regev is
playing a major part in that to actually
sequence representatives from all of
your trillions of cells and see how they
differ and then there's cancer genome
projects and precision medicine sequence
every type of cancer cell find out
what's different about it and precisely
figure out how to treat it all very
exciting things and then of course
there's synthetic genomes where you can
literally build a cell and its genome
program it to do what you want hopefully
and then there's one of the things that
your generation will have to deal with
and that's all the
data because we we've just found ways to
churn it out but you guys are gonna have
to do the heavy lifting there so DNA
then looking at that structure is
packaged into cells so figure this one
out each human cell has 1.8 meters of
DNA in it yet it fits into a cell that's
10 to 100 microns in diameter and it's
bundled tightly up so you'll learn how
DNA in cells gets bundled up and wrapped
around proteins that neutralize the
negative charges of the double-stranded
DNA with positively charged proteins and
enable packaging so we will talk about
all of this when is DNA unraveled what
signals it's unraveling because in order
to copy it you've got to unpack it so
these are a lot of details about DNA
that you'll be able to sort of have much
more sense of as we move forward cells
are different in size I just mentioned
to you
a typical eukaryotic cell is about 10 to
100 microns in diameter
a typical bacterial cell is about 1 to
10 microns so there's a vast difference
in sizes for these simple simple cells
that have no nucleus relative to the
cells that are compartmentalized and
perform a lot of functions so we will
learn to appreciate that difference in
size looking at the building blocks that
go into all of them but then
understanding how bigger cells have to
have a lot more complexity in their
signaling in order to establish their
functions but also interact with other
cells in multicellular organisms we're
still doing pine for thymus the other
thing that we will spend several classes
on is imaging and visualization of
things going on in cells so what we'll
talk to you about is the discovery of
fluorescent proteins which have provided
an unparalleled opportunity to label
proteins within living organisms in
order to track what they do and through
the efforts of protein engineers
there is an entire panel of colored
proteins that fluoresce at different
wavelengths that we can use to study
biology in live systems in real-time
these slides show you a little bit of
that I love these pictures just showing
a dividing cell where the chromosomes
you see red because the histones are
labeled with red fluorescent protein and
all that green fuzzy stuff or
microtubules around we can do this now
you couldn't do this 15 years ago
observe these changes we can also look
at changes as cells divide and go
through the cell cycle one of my
favorites is this we're going through
the stages to program a cell to divide a
new protein gets made and then it
settles down but then when you go to
divide again you keep making you
cyclically make different sets of
proteins and you can observe them in
real time dividing so just think if you
were trying to make a chemo therapeutic
where you wanted to stop cell division
or you wanted to inhibit one of those
proteins you could literally watch it
function does it get in to cell does it
disrupt the normal pattern of cell
division so these are capabilities that
are now really are available so I've
talked to you about cells but I'm gonna
pass you over to Professor Martin now
for a little bit
thank you so this is one of my favorite
model organisms this is a fruit fly at
larger than real size and so one topic
that I'll start on when I start
lecturing either at the end of this
month or the beginning of October is
we'll talk a lot about genetics and one
thing we'll start on is pioneering
research done in this system to
establish the chromosome theory of
inheritance okay and we'll talk about
the importance in model organisms and
discovering new biology but in addition
to that I also want to talk about how
genetics will affect you guys as you go
on and graduate from MIT and go into
your own careers because genetics is
really playing an important role in all
our lives and already you guys have the
option to get your DNA genotypes right
there are lots of companies now like
23andme and ancestry.com where you can
get your DNA genotyped and you can learn
about your ancestry you can learn about
whether you might be predisposed towards
certain diseases and so in order to
appreciate the data you get back from
these companies you really have to
understand something about genetics and
another thing which I find very
fascinating are ethical issues that come
up with the use of such sites and you
might have seen this in the news last
semester
both forensic X experts and police I
identified a suspect in a killing that
happened 40 years ago and this was in
part due to using the suspects family
tree okay and so they use the family
tree or some you know the skys relatives
and Dunn's one of these ancestry coms
and they use the information from DNA
acquired from other individuals to track
down this other individual okay so one
thing that I find incredibly exciting
about biology is that it is truly
dynamic okay and this is a human
neutrophil and it's just a bright field
microscopy nothing's labeled and what
you're seeing here is this this
neutrophil is chasing after this
bacterium and it illustrates another
concept that we'll talk about in this
course which is signaling so this
neutrophil is receiving a signal from
this bacteria the
tells it where it is and it's then able
to chase that bacterium and track it
down and there you see it just got the
bacterium okay
so we'll talk about dynamic processes
that cells do and and how that's
important for their function in addition
to considering single cells we also want
to understand how entire organisms and
tissues work and I want to emphasize
that yes we have sequence or researchers
have sequenced the human genome and the
genomes of many different organisms okay
and that's great right we have this this
data set but we still don't understand
how all the components that are in the
genome are wired together and work in
order to create a complicated organism
like ourselves okay and so one aspect of
that which is mysterious is how does the
genome encodes shape okay
how do we get our shape and how do we
get the shape of our organs and this is
something that my lab is interested in
and so this is a fruit fly embryo and
you can see at the beginning here this
is three hours into development you just
have a smooth surface for this embryo
but during development this changes and
I'm just showing you here a
cross-section of the same embryo you see
it's a sheet of cells that surrounds a
central yolk okay and this changes three
hours into development because a
population of about a thousand cells in
this organism fold to form a crease okay
so this is a dramatic shape change for
this embryo it goes from being a single
layer to now having multiple layers so
this is a time course here showing you
how cells change shape in this tissue
and how this leads to what's initially a
single layer of cells to become two
layers of cells and this process is
similar to saw more for genetic events
that happen in human embryos but we can
study this
in fruit fly embryos or many other model
systems in order to try to understand
mechanistically how this happens so
again this is dynamic and I want to show
you a movie that shows you the dynamics
of this process so now this is an embryo
that's been labeled with some of these
fluorescent proteins that professor and
peri Olli just introduced ones green
that's the and it's showed here in green
and the other is a red fluorescent
protein in red the red fluorescent
protein is marking individual cells the
green protein is a motor protein that
generates force and what you see is
where the motor protein is this is where
the tissue contracts and this is where
the tissue folds okay and so because
we're able to see these proteins in
action we can infer how they're
functioning during development to
essentially program tissue shape and
there are many other opportunities where
even though we have the genome we still
don't understand how collectives of
proteins or collectives of cells are
sort of interacting with each other to
sort of create emergent properties that
are what are responsible for padding
patterning is something as large as a
human another thing that we'll talk
about is how cells divide and this is
another fruit fly embryo and it's
labeling histones so it labels the DNA
and so you're seeing nuclei here divided
sequentially it'll be one more division
and then it's going to stop okay and my
point here is that cell division during
development and in adults is under
exquisite control okay and a breakdown
of this control is important in the
progression of cancer so we're gonna
talk about how cells control whether or
not they divide and how this is impacted
in cancer cells I also want to point out
the
this video is from Eric wish shells who
is uh at Princeton University okay let's
hit the Lights I have one last thing
just to mention so I just want to
reinforce what Professor Imperioli said
we have a small class so this is really
an opportunity to have this be more
interactive than it would be if we had
like 300 people in the class so I want
to really encourage you guys to ask
questions also if you have ideas we
would love to hear them
and I want to try one new thing this
semester so I find that students are a
little hesitant to come to my office
hours so this year I want to hold what
I'm good
calling running hours so one thing that
I really like to do is I like to run and
I've noticed that many of my students
are also runners because I'll like see
them out around the river and so I just
want to hold sort of weekly running
hours I'm gonna choose three o'clock not
three hour run all right 3 p.m. on
Fridays and we'll just meet in my office
and so if you like to run you can just
meet there we'll go on a run around the
Charles and this is not a competitive
event
I'm not some fitness nut I ran home last
week and I ate half a bag of swedish
fish on the way so it's not a
competition it's just to try to get to
know you guys and to try to break the
ice in sort of a non-academic way okay
so I'm just gonna wrap up here so we've
bombed you with a quite a lot of yes
over there you want to know more about
running yeah or you could join me at
CrossFit if you would like as well
we will both have office hours and we
will post them and we welcome you to
come visit us and you know find out more
tell us more about yourselves
we're fountains of information so
basically over the first half of the
course we tend to cover foundations and
so we build on biochemistry one of my
favorite subjects where we cover all of
the molecules of life what are all the
bits it takes to make a cell lipids
sugars proteins nucleic acids then we
synthesize them all together where we
show in molecular biology how the genome
encodes the proteome and what happens to
the proteome after that so you'll see me
for all of those lectures then I will
hand you over to Professor Martin for
genetics for the learning how to
manipulate DNA and we'll cap off this
first phase of work with cell signaling
and understanding much more about
dynamics of cells as opposed to static
building blocks but you've got to
understand the building blocks before
you can understand the complexity that's
why I really like to cover those
molecules at a reasonable depth it's
kind of ridiculous for classes but
nevertheless that's how we start for
some of you you've seen some of it
before for others you've seen none of it
before it doesn't matter we will we will
give you our flavor on it if your
chemistry is a little weak I suggest you
read the textbook there's a couple of
sections on just chemical covalent and
non-covalent bonding then you'll need to
do the first pset if your chemistry is
strong you're fine
if your chemistry is weak and you need a
little help I'll run an extra session
next week we can take care of every
eventualities because you're a smaller
class and then we'll take it from there
and then what I really want to do is
encourage you to do the reading make
sure you're in a recitation and next
time but it's in the sidebar I'd like
you to take a look at the sliding scale
which shows you the dimensions of
molecules macromolecules and organisms
which I find
rather call even though it's probably
built for high school students okay
that's it from us for now
you